Nos preguntan,
¿cuáles de estas rectas son paralelas?
Rectas paralelas son rectas que tienen la
misma pendiente,
son rectas distintas y que nunca se intersectan.
Tenemos que buscar entonces, rectas que son
distintas y que tienen la misma pendiente,
Para nuestra fortuna, todas estas rectas están
en la forma "y" igual a "mx" más "b"
o forma pendiente ordenada,
así es que, para todas estas rectas,
simplemente por inspección vamos a
determinar la pendiente.
Entonces, para la recta A, tenemos que la
pendiente es igual a 2, aquí la tenemos,
la pendiente de la recta es igual a 2.
Para la recta B, la pendiente es igual a 3...
la pendiente de la recta B es igual a 3.
Estas dos primeras rectas, no son paralelas,
las vamos a graficar
en un momento para que las veamos,
pero no son paralelas.
Para la recta C... lo voy a poner en púrpura...
la pendiente es igual a 2...
la pendiente de la recta C es igual a 2, entonces tenemos que la recta C y la recta A son paralelas,
pues tienen la misma pendiente y son rectas
distintas pues su ordenada al origen es diferente.
Grafiquemos entonces estas rectas.
Tenemos primero la recta A,
la recta A que pasa por 0, -6,
así 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, el punto 0, 6.
Y la pendiente es 2, uno a la derecha,
dos para arriba...
uno a la derecha, dos para arriba...
Dos a la derecha, cuatro para arriba, estamos
sobre la misma recta, otros dos para la derecha,
cuatro para arriba... cuatro para arriba.
Y ahí ya tenemos suficientes puntos para
trazar la línea.
Trazamos entonces la línea que une esos puntos,
aquí tenemos esa línea recta A...
Déjame hacerla mejor... déjame tratar de
hacer más recta... aquí la tenemos... bueno,
es lo mejor que lo puedo hacer...
Esta es la recta A.
Tracemos la recta B.
La recta B, tiene ordenada al origen -6, también
pasa por el punto 0, -6,
nada más que la pendiente en este caso es 3, es una mayor pendiente, grafiquémosla.
Entonces cuando "x" avanza 1, "y" eleva en
3, cuando "x"avanza en 2,
"y" se eleva en 6, 2, 4, 6... cuando "x" avanza en 2,
"y" se eleva en 6.
Entonces tenemos la recta...
Déjame dibujarla lo más recto posible...
aquí la tenemos... ¡y aquí la tenemos!...
Es una recta con una mayor pendiente, cuando
"x" se incrementa en 1,
el crecimiento en "y" para esta recta en azul, es mucho mayor que para la recta roja.
Aquí tenemos la recta B,
estas dos rectas se intersectan,
por lo cual definitivamente no son paralelas.
Finalmente la recta C, que tiene una ordenada
al origen de 5, vamos a ubicarla,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, aquí la tenemos, el punto
0, 5 y la pendiente es de 2,
avanzamos en 1 para "x" y elevamos en 2 para "y",
si disminuyes en 1 para "x", vas a disminuir en 2 para "y",
tiene la misma relación, la misma relación
que teníamos aquí de 2 a 1,
es la misma que -2 a -1.
Hacemos lo mismo, trazamos varios puntos con
esa pendiente, si disminuimos en 2 para "x",
tenemos que disminuir en 4 para "y"...
2, 4... 4 para "y"... déjame ubicar otro punto más,
ya tenemos un número suficiente de puntos.
Vamos a trazar la recta C.
Así que uniendo estos puntos, obtenemos la recta C.
Y nota que la recta A y la recta C, nunca
se intersectan, tienen la misma pendiente.
Tienen distinta ordenada al origen, pero tienen
la misma pendiente, se están incrementando
se están incrementando a la misma razón,
pero nunca se van a intersectar.
Es por eso que, la recta A y C,
son rectas paralelas.